[Music]
the beginning of this third Despicable
Me group receives news that he has a
brother named drew Oh ready to be
villains together no I left that life
behind me just one nice mmm I called the
black one when they get together it's
hilarious how about we steal the largest
diamond in the world it's a very
interesting dynamic between the two of
them also cuz they're both played by the
same person wait did we just finish
other's sentences drew is sort of the
alter ego of group he's very light very
silly Oh doesn't love this guy look at
him open hair would make you better
what GRU makes things much more
seriously this is not like stealing
lollipops whoa I've impressed my kids
friends by pulling out the GRU voice
every now and then you're dead getaway
driver
Oh with any luck I'll be able to pull
out the drew voice and get the same
reaction it's go time
[Music]
shortly after you and your brother were
born your father and I divorced and we
each took one son obviously ha ha ha
I got second pick I have a twin brother
hey brother finally meeting you back
your discomfort is al-arian
so how are things career-wise haha great
you let these most-wanted village just
get away you're fired Zaza great
crashing it I brought you here to
continue the family business Lily's in
your blood and broken boobs I left that
life behind me I understand hmm I wonder
what this does
holy-moly become a villain again
what did you guys do today there's
always a blind guy
nothing
what my
hello what about that for what Oh girls
learn to appreciate me differentiate
we've been waiting a long time it was so
fluffy no you two are villains now ah I
mean hello sweety barinova kissing
[Music]